und wir blicken jetzt in den Iran
Billstedt jetzt nämlich auf der
Terrorliste des Iran weil wir frei und
ehrlich mit Klartext berichten über das
molaregime und über die mutigen Proteste
gegen diese islamische Diktatur ja das
ist hier diese Terrorliste der Mullahs
wir schauen mal rein und da sehen sie
hier auf der Seite des iranischen
Außenministeriums mittlerweile auch die
Namen der beiden bildchefs nicht ganz
korrekt geschrieben aber das sind
Johannes Boje und Alexandra würzbach das
bedeutet Sanktionen jetzt gegen diese
beiden auch keine Einreise in Iran ich
glaube hatten beide in naher Zukunft
auch nicht vor aber da steht im man
drohe mit der Beschlagnahme ihres
Eigentums im Hoheitsgebiet des Iran so
heißt das Bild also auf dieser Iran
Terrorliste und für uns bei Bild heißt
das ganz klar wir berichten natürlich
weiter immer weiter über die
Grausamkeiten des molaregimes ja so wie
heute wir zeigen nämlich genau das wir
zeigen mit welcher Gewalt der Iran gegen
den friedlichen Protest auf den Straßen
vorgeht der Iran das ist der Staat in
dem Menschen an ihnen hängen
[Applaus]
laute Schüsse fliehende Menschen Feuer
auf den Straßen Szenen wie aus einem
Krieg ein Krieg den das molaregime im
Iran gegen seine Bürger führt
[Musik]
trotzdem die Menschen verlieren ihre
Angst ihre Angst gegen ihn den obersten
Führer Ali harmonei
der 83-Jährige ist seit 1989 das
politische und religiöse Oberhaupt des
mörderischen Regimes der Islamischen
Republik Iran die Proteste fallen auf
den 40-tägigen Trauertag für die Heldin
in diesem Krieg dem Krieg für die
Freiheit
Masson Amini die Mitte September von der
iranischen Sittenpolizei verhaftet wird
deren Vorwurf ihre Uni islamische
Kleidung
dieses Verhalten das den Tod von
Menschen verursacht ist nicht richtig
ich glaube nicht dass es mit der
Auffassung des Islam übereinstimmt die
Menschen gehen auf die Straßen rufen
Frauen Leben Freiheit fordern den Tod
von Ali harmony
doch der schlägt zurück mit gezielten
Tötungen Folter Entführungen
seit Beginn der Proteste töten die
Mullahs über 250 Menschen mehr als 1200
werden festgenommen ihnen droht die
Todesstrafe weil sie Krieg gegen Gott
führen würden mutige Frauen wie die
gerade mal 23-Jährige Hanoi Kia die
17-jährige Nicole schackeremy die
32-Jährige gossauliche Wali und die
22-Jährige neging Abo moleki sind unter
den Opfern
sie wurden mit Stockschlägen
totgeprügelt oder erschossen
seit 33 Jahren hält Olli Home & naey die
Zügel dieses brutalen Systems gegen die
eigenen Menschen fest in der Hand
Ebrahim Resi ist der Präsident des
Landes
auch der General Hussein Salami ist für
den terrorverantwortlich er führt die
210.000 Mann starke iranische
revolutionsgarten die nicht nur im
Ausland Anschläge planen sondern auch im
eigenen Land ihre Leute unterdrücken mit
Verfolgungen und Massenhinrichtungen
im ewigen Gefängnis werden Menschen
gezielt gefoltert in Tiran sind jeden
Tag 7000 der sittenpolizisten in Zivil
unterwegs belästigen vor allem Frauen
wenn sie sich nicht an die
Kleidervorschriften halten trotzdem sie
werden nicht leise die mutigen Frauen
aus dem Iran
ja und wir zeigen Ihnen die neuesten
beeindruckenden Bilder der mutigen
Proteste im Iran 10.000 Menschen laufen
pilgern im Nordiran zu der Grabstätte
von Masson Amini der Frau die vor 40
Tagen im Zuge der Proteste getötet wurde
ja mit ihrer Geschichte hat dieser
Protest ja erst richtig Fahrt
aufgenommen im Iran und all diese
Menschen die Sie hier sehen so weit das
Auge reicht die protestieren wie Sie
sehen können friedlich ganz anders
heißes die Terrororganisation die mischt
jetzt auch noch mit in dieser wackligen
Situation im Iran mit einem Blutbad in
einem schiitischen Schrein in der Stadt
Shiraz kurz vorm Gebet schießt dort
einen Terrorist mindestens 15 Menschen
nieder das hier die schrecklichen Bilder
des Terrors im Iran bei uns im Studio
unser Bild Kollege Ehmann sefati der im
Iran geboren ist hi Ehmann was macht das
mit dir wenn du diese Zustände und auch
diese Bilder gerade hier in deinem
Heimatland siehst
wir erleben seit fast 40 Tage ein
kompletten andere Iran ein Iran wo die
Menschen mutige iranische Frauen und
Männer auf die Straße gehen für Freiheit
für Demokrat Demokratie
Gleichberechtigung und natürlich auch
für Frieden
wir erleben
ich muss tatsächlich sagen diese Bilder
sind schön diese Bilder zeigen wie diese
neue Generation gegen Unterdrücker
kämpft wir haben gestern zwei Videos aus
Iran erhalten eine Video zeigt wie die
mensch-frauen ohne Kopftücher
ihre Brüste auf die Knie gehen und sagen
schieß mich es schießt mich doch schießt
mich doch oder in andere Video wo
ein Iraner
revolutionsgrade stoppen wie das haben
wir vorhin eine Maske gezeigt das zeigt
dass diese Menschen mit leere Hände
gegen Unterdrücker kämpfen und das sind
schöne Bilder das sind tatsächlich wie
würdest du das im Moment
ein bisschen was wir da sehen ist das
eine Art Bürgerkrieg mittlerweile schon
ist das eine Revolution die da gerade
aufzieht lieber Kai das ist kein Burger
King das ist eine Revolution das ist wie
Iraner wir waren noch nie so ein
einheitliche Volk äh baluten azariskoden
Phasen aus überall egal wo man im Iran
geboren ist man wir haben
zusammengehalten die letzte 40 Tage und
wir haben nur ein gemeinsamer Feind und
das ist die iranische Beschattung das
Regie kann das Müller Regime tatsächlich
fallen
ich muss sagen ja definitiv der Sieg war
noch nie so nah spurbar
dass diese Bilder was wir aus Iran
erhalten das zeigt dass das iranisches
Volk Segen wird und natürlich brauchen
wir aber ausländische Unterstützung und
darunter auch
westliche Medien und auf die
Aufmerksamkeit ja Bild berichtet darüber
immer wieder dass es unsere
Verpflichtung auch heute ganz groß in
der Zeitung und hier bei Bild live das
hat eben auch zur Folge dass jetzt zwei
weitere Namen auf der iranischen
Terrorliste stehen nämlich die unserer
Chefredakteure was bedeutet das auch für
dich irgendetwas für dein Leben macht
dir das Angst nicht Angst überhaupt
nicht aber das ist eine Auszeichnung für
uns für Bild für alle bildmitarbeiter
das zeigt dass wir auf den richtigen Weg
sind und da wir seit mindestens gestern
wissen dass der iranische Diktator
Lochham Mini auch bild folgt nur zwei
Sätze auf Persisch schau mal telesi
baboyad auf Deutsch du bist ein
Kindermörder und du musst mein Land
verlassen live gesendet nach Teheran
danke Ihnen servati unser Bild Kollegen
[Musik]